yes
I think the movie is a love who you are
story and celebrate who you are story
with each of our four characters they
start off in a place where they're
either denying a part of themselves or
not wanting to confront a part of
themselves and of course when the
debauchery and chaos and the madness
sort of breaks open all of them are
forced to truly Embrace who they are
yeah and I love that I think it's really
special
it's meant the world to me that I get
the opportunity to like perform and with
people I've admired from afar for so
long Bravo
well massive huge fans of Seth Rogen and
point gray and their movies and super
bad and just like his entire sensibility
like they have R-rated movies just down
they are joyful they're raw they're real
they're Unapologetic and they just go
For Broke you know what we've gone this
far
we'll figure it out
so we knew really early on like those
were gonna be the perfect Partners For
Us in bringing Joy right to life
oh wow
[Applause]